i was
lonely and
in the morning it would be training to the left tired
next i came to the dns palette this
role is some kind of psychologist work you
guys work
will be dead how much i don’t know i’m not
just a bear cheekbones and
smoking building listened to the blows
came here to the place agree to
appreciate everything is normal
together, the repair of the
tractor began
widely
withus
, and not so tragically, like
today's Russian missile attack
on Odessa, then on the region with a whole one, but
for the Ukrainian framework to be so
peaceful, like wounds, skin stools and ti
Europe for the first century, I even
want obse who needs Jeanne today  in
sieges with small shoes zak
gas mask happy with the European choice I
fight for our state fight for ukraine
for you and me about 23 power to the
cob pavel bure about membership so
intensively this xana because I will
see the shafts of rechennya about the candidate today in
what  zolin ya vasya parting the european
union
procedure and throat
children of the russian court has no right to this
n  and when we don’t do this,
I can only
operate with facts, the
facts say
that I’m a mini athlete was
detained with illegal drugs
that contained narcotic substances
in Russian law, there
really are those
that provide for
punishment for such a crime,
but again, this is just a statement that’s
what she was with  detained and what is in
our legislation about the plan already
making some kind of verdicts, this is only a
court can